you have a few people you've worked with
who are fascinating like yourself
quentin tarantino you work with him
uh when somebody asks you to describe
him with one word you said encyclopedia
what have you learned from the guy about
filmmaking about life again
a very generous man with his knowledge
and for me
he shared it i think in a way that was
unique in the sense of
you know at a point in time
you know we just was super duper tight
like you know like i'm going to his crib
and watching movies and
and just having long conversations about
art and about life
you know i mean
um so i learned a lot i consider him you
know especially when it comes to
anything cinematic in my life
i consider him the godfather of that for
me
i think um
you know i i humbly asked him to mentor
me which is a very humbling thing to do
coming from my neighborhood coming from
who i am
coming from i was already a
multi-platinum
artist
you know with
i mean it was a year it was past the
year 2000 already so it's like 2001 2002
that i asked
him to mentor me so
i was the lizard
yeah you know what i mean but i humbled
myself because
i saw him
a craft of brain power
that to me resonated with me but i was
just a padaman and i was a nervous at it
um because i was trying to make movies
and my music
you know trying to make videos and
here was a man who was a master of an
encyclopedia of it as well
and uh like film history film history
from whether it's the actor the director
the cinematographer yeah maybe even the
costume designer he may know 50 60 he
made one of the 50 greatest costume
designers in his memory
yeah i mean
this guy's brain both of you have pretty
good memory
i'd love to be a fly on the wall that
conversation yeah and kung fu movies
mostly you guys we actually started
i think we we we started our
relationship
trying to outdo each other
knowledge-wise or what yeah movie
knowledge-wise
actually kung fu movie knowledge-wise
and i think that cat it was another
category i wouldn't have had a chance
but at least in that category yeah i was
pretty holding my weight who won
you know what
i'll be honest and say that
i may
have said a few he didn't see yeah but
quentin is older than me yeah
so he could go back
further yeah he could go back to 72
well i didn't see one yet you know i
mean yeah yeah well we uh he said master
of the flying guillotine that i got a
chance to uh that you commentate over
today and i got a chance to see the
screening of he said that's one of his
favorites
uh for you
uh the
36th chamber of shaolin now the master
killer is your favorite best best ever
would you say that's the greatest kung
fu
i mean movie ever
it def it's hard to say the greatest
ever right because somebody may make
another one and
it depends on your own phase of life but
i'll i will put that first
if i want to introduce somebody to kung
fu movies that's that's a beautiful
entry
you